carrières sous poissy l'une des villes
yvelinoise n'ai plus touché par les
intempéries
ce dimanche valérie pécresse y est rendu
avec les élus de la vallée de la seine
ils ont fait le tour de la ville en bus
mais aussi à pied sur les bords de seine
pour constater l'étendue des dégâts
j'ai réuni à carrières sous poissy la
plupart des maires de la vallée de seine
qui est qui ont été touchés notamment la
plaine de montesson qui a été sous l'eau
donc il y avait le maire de mesnil le
roi le maire de montesson le maire de
poissy qui aujourd'hui organise les
évacuations le maire de vilaine bref
tous les maires qui ont été touchés et
qui nuit et jour aujourd'hui travaillent
à rétablir la situation pour leurs
habitants un fonds d'urgence d'un
million d'euros a déjà été annoncé par
la région pour aider les petites
communes à carrières sous poissy 46
habitants ont dû être évacués mais la
difficulté majeure ce sont les véhicules
de 150 caravanes de gens du voyage ont
été mises à l'abri à l'aide de tracteurs
et plus de 1400 voitures ont été
déplacées en 24 heures un record
nous avons dû évacuer compte tenu de la
montée puisque là nous sommes à 22
mètres de plafond de crue comme on dit
un de plateau de crue donc là on a
évacué tous les 1400 garage dans tous
les 1400 véhicules du quartier des bords
de seine sur des parkings que nous avons
défini donc sur carrières sous poissy à
peu près une quinzaine de parking
intempéries et grève met les franciliens
en difficulté à quelques jours de leur
eau valérie pécresse en charge notamment
des transports en ile de france est en
colère contre les grévistes
je demande solennellement grévistes de
la sncf par esprit de solidarité et avec
70 parlementaires de toute
l'ile-de-france tous les parlementaires
des yvelines le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines
je demande de suspendre la grève parce
qu'on ne peut pas ajouter de la galère à
la galère et que quand toute l'île de
france est en vrac
quand les franciliens sont vraiment dans
la détresse c'est vraiment pas le moment
de défendre des revendications
catégorielles la grève ou y
il c'est possible c'est un droit c'est
constitutionnel mais pas en ce moment il
faudra attendre la décrue pour estimer
le coût économique de ces intempéries
sur le réseau ferroviaire d'île de
france
guillaume pepy président de la sncf a
déjà annoncé que les conséquences se
chiffreront en dizaines de millions
d'euros